this morning on the dish Eric agapong
born and raised here in New York by
parents from Ghana his cooking reflects
the flavors and influences of African
cultures and the Melting Pot of America
too he gave Fame on a national cooking
show and he's used it to push for access
to fresh healthy foods in underserved
communities I joined him for a taste of
his personal mission and his tantalizing
cuisine
I grew up in a really traditional West
African home but then you imagine me as
a New York City kid I had uh you know
neighbors that are Albanian and Italian
and Jamaican so it was just eclectic so
I'm so thankful I fell into this
profession this industry culinary I can
kind of pick up from all of that Tamara
one of my favorite ingredients
throughout the entire world to use with
an appreciation for all global Cuisine
Chef Eric agapong's particularly focused
on food from his homeland no one else is
cooking the food that I'm cooking case
in point one is the first chef to bring
West African food to the fight season 16
of Top Chef where he showcased
Delicacies from Ghana I'm doing a West
African dumpling called Fufu taking
viewers through a history of the
transatlantic slave trade Eric what did
you make for us today I made a Caribbean
Jerk Tartar and Lotus fruit chips it's
an unfortunate story but it's one that
we can't forget the amazing food that
has traveled from West Africa to
essentially the American South and
there's a beautiful lineage of all these
ingredients that you might see over here
as well so it didn't come without
comment maybe like a few days into the
competition and there was a chef who
came to me and said you can chill on the
African stuff like you don't have to do
it all the time as if you would tell an
Italian chef to not make pasta so it was
something that I internalized and kind
of used as fuel as well and wanted to
actually do more right and almost one I
really almost won that that season which
was insane
[Music]
Eric
please pack your knives and go
I think I wanted so many other ways I
put food out there that hasn't been seen
before I talked about food to judges
with amazing pallets that hadn't you
know eaten this food before and I think
I left a decent Mark in the end do you
think it hurt hurt you and your chances
no no I'm sitting in front of Michelle
right now and I'm having that like this
I've done so many cool things and
sitting in front of a meal that while
personal includes a bit of business I'm
an ambassador for battery farming and
we're using a lot of their products
right now but indoor Farms that bring
Fresh Foods to urban communities this is
the baby Kelsey's salad that we have
right here so it's baby kale we have a
little bit of dandelions and Panko bread
crumbs a little bit of shaved Parmesan
then we have this beautiful Green
Goddess Caesar dressing right here man I
just dig in it
besides his non-traditional Caesar
there's his roasted carrots the root
vegetables the root vegetables exactly
right baked roasted cod with peanut
sauce I love using these Indigent
ingredients and a really creative way
and his chickpea stew this is really
just an homage to a lot of the Caribbean
flavors that I love and you really do
love Caribbean food I love the flavor I
mean the scotch it's all like a huge
line right I think about the ingredients
that are used in West Africa greens are
used in like the Caribbean islands and
ingredients that are used in like the
American South he showed me how he uses
ingredients from across the diaspora so
now that we have everything really nice
and kind of cooked down to make his
famous stew it's time to add in some of
our tomato paste we're gonna build build
some Flavor now
add about a couple of teaspoons
I like it
perfect this is great all right I'm
gonna add some curry powder in that now
oh
I'm liking this dish
okay now we can go ahead and kind of
deglaze it with some chicken sauce look
at that
hold up it's perfect
and we chop some of those scallions what
I love about the skyline obviously you
can have that
fresh so you can have it Cooks we're
doing it both here
at Japan offered a lot of cooking
classes online during the pandemic today
we took Chef Eric's class making the
jollof risotto we've taken a lot of
cooking classes but this was hands down
the best ever here is our final product
we had the best time take the class yeah
which allowed more time with his
daughter Linux look at the flick of the
wrist to refine her staple a favorite
pancake souffles and I actually did that
yesterday not quite literally I made a
pancake oh my God it's so funny that you
said that what was hard to chew on
losing a concept based on his favorite
Caribbean street food called Doubles I
did like a whole menu at a space open in
Washington DC we had the grand opening
we had the date and then the pandemic
happened so it was a gift and a curse so
to speak why a gift and a curse a curse
because at the time I couldn't see the
forest through the trees the blessing of
it all is all the things that I did
afterwards if I I wasn't able to make
the food for the folks in Washington DC
why not teach people all over the world
how to make the food anyway and that
opened the doors for so many other
things his three degrees in culinary
arts and nutrition didn't hurt either a
triple threat he credits with his TV
success as contestant the winner of
today's challenge is Eric judge 40
minutes left guys 40 minutes and now
host so without further Ado the Iron
Chef herself a new gig that teams in
with Chef Alex Guarnaschelli I'm putting
all my years of reputation on the line
and I wouldn't have it any other way in
Alex versus America
you're like Pat Sajak I'm doing it all
now it's insane and I think again the
pandemic was really that like
um I think they feel like life before
like BC and 80 like this is like
pandemic was really like a turning point
and so many crazy things that I did not
even think of started happening um and I
got just the power saying yes and being
at the right place at the right time
what is the next thing you want to do I
want brick and mortar I want to own
restaurants I want to build my or
continue to grow my brand I have some
really really exciting projects
um that are really going to help out
with that I'm looking to expand the idea
of what African food can look like on a
fine dining scale on a quick service
scale I want to do this internationally
I want to do in the Caribbean islands so
I have uh lofty plans to keep you know
stretching my wings yeah I already know
yeah
I've
I think I know he's right on the cusp of
making a big announcement uh but we I
have brought food I see that I can't say
that a strawberry galette and his
roasted carrots with his fresh greens
amazing all are features of Bowery
farming which is a hydroponic Farm there
are different spaces primarily in
Maryland right now but he is very big on
pushing uh urban communities and access
to Fresh Produce so this is all about it
I this strawberry Gillette is the
strawberry dish pops it's really good
it's Super Fresh I love the Caribbean
dishes look great in it too no the
street dishes
there is nothing better than doubles I'm
just saying doubles are like the taco of
the Caribbean but even better and you
know I love me some tacos it's really
really good oh yes